dear friends hope you guys are doing
well welcome to my channel
i'm gonna get straight into it inshallah
as you guys know um
brother adam saleh um has released a
new video i just want to make something
clear the reason i'm doing this video is
not
for adam because that's done that's
dusted we've advised him
that's halal that's done i'm not gonna
go and repeat myself if somebody is not
understanding something
or not accepting or willing to talk and
engage then there's no point
my video is not for adam's side yeah
even though if you watch watching
benefits then inshallah he does if he
doesn't that's not my concern
to me what is the main concern is the
youth that are watching him because he
doesn't have that concern he doesn't
care um how he affects the youth he
doesn't care about that
all he cares about and nobody can come
and say this is judging in no way shape
or form
is all he cares about is that from his
actions we need to be very clear
if something looks like a duck and
quacks like a duck
we call that a duck we don't go and
start saying oh no this that etc you
don't know what's in his heart
blah blah i'm sorry i'm not here to
insult him but he said nothing like that
i ask allah to guide him
and guide myself i don't know how my end
is going to be i don't know how his end
is going to be
he might repent and turn around etc i
don't know where i'm at where i might be
so i'm not here to look down on him
because we're all sinners
and the best of sin is the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him said are
those who
repent so inshallah he does repent from
this and understand
that the material gain of this life
money cars girls etc this is not going
to bring you happiness
especially at the cost of your religion
but anyways let's watch it and we'll
take it from the each other this is
really shocking what he says just watch
this
and people are saying oh you need a you
need a you need to know where you're
going to say that they judge me like
the day judgment is going to be me there
not you look at this guys
this is what a lot of people say on the
day of judgement it's gonna be me not
you
when somebody says it sometimes you
think to yourself is their judgment
gonna be like
like a walk in the path is that gonna be
like you know you chilling on the beach
you know and then allah is there just
asking you questions and you're just
answering
do you know what the day of judgment
means anybody that understands what
they're saying
when they're saying the day of judgment
anybody that comprehends the words that
you're uttering
would shiver and would be scared
to say that allah is going to judge me
not you the one who's made you
from despised fluid made you into what
you are today
sustains you sustains everything in the
heavens on the earth
who's made all of this is going to take
you into account the day of judgment
and all you can say is this
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and people are saying oh you need a you
need a you need to know where you're
going to say the day judgment like
the day judgment is going to be me there
not you so they should focus on
everyone's sins in their own way you
know so basically what he's trying to
say is
let me sin in peace i just want to sin
in peace you can sin in peace
don't drag the youth down there with you
you do what you want to do yeah
you do what you want to do but don't let
other people don't drag
down there with you my dad reacting to
all you can handle
official music videos
i was absolutely shocked that he
that he went and showed this to his
father his father
but then again it makes you wonder if
somebody can
openly not give a damn and care about
the lord that's watching him his creator
his maker then again the question that
needs to be asked is we really care
about his father watching it
like even his dad you can see it from
his face that he's
inside cringing you know and the thing
is it's
for somebody to like i would rather i
don't know like i would rather go
under the earth than show my father
a woman a non-mahram woman
licking my face licking my face i would
rather go underneath the earth then
show my father and to be honest i would
rather go more underneath the earth
then do that knowing the one who's
created the heavens and the earth
that's created all of us the most
merciful
the most forgiving that
allah is watching and you do this in
public like it's public you share it out
there
if the prophet saws said every sinner
will be forgiven except
those who sin openly they expose their
sins
not only you're exposing you you're
you're showing it to your family members
and it's a simple question brother and
sister i want to ask you guys very
simple
i don't know if you guys remember there
was a video i just want you guys to see
as well here
where adam saudi clearly says if anybody
in my yemeni culture if anybody asks
about my mother or my sister's name
it's a very disrespectful thing don't
ever ask a yemeni person what's their
mom's name or what's their sister's name
i can't and i will never ever say my
mom's name in public i can't even show
her on camera it's all about respect
with the yemeni culture
so when it's your mother and your own
sister it's calm nobody come near them
you protect them
and rightly so you should but when it's
other people's sisters in other people's
daughters
it's okay they can come and lick your
face you can be in a bed with them
it's fine it's normal to me that's
hypocrisy that's double standards
because i ask a simple question and i
ask you guys
to ask this to brother adam fans that
you watch please please
i just want one thing you want just ask
him would he
allow his own sister and i'm not talking
about you little girl
may allah bless her and keep her safe
from this disgusting behavior
may allah keep her safe i'm sure if i'm
not mistaken
he has a sister yeah would he ever
allow his own sister to be in a music
video
with another man with another man and
allow that man to be in bed with his own
sister
and allow that allow his sister to lick
that man's face
simple question simple question yeah
would he ever allow that because he
would never do that
and the evidence is that the fact that
he in that video said don't even ask my
mother or my sister's name let alone
being in a vid
what don't even ask their name look how
protective he is
they don't care about you while he they
do not
care a single dumb about you they don't
care
all they care about is the money that
enters their pocket
every time a video comes out youtube
video you're making money they care
about money and this is a gradual step
that you see
first it was hugging sisters then it was
kissing sisters then it was invited them
to shisha
bars then you had girls twerking on you
yeah and footages came out et cetera now
it's come to the point where you're
making music videos where you don't give
a damn you don't care now
you've crossed that limit now you use
the muslims now it's like okay now i'm
that's what's happening but anyways this
maybe his father you know would not be
affected effect affected from it as much
he's a grown adult he's in his maybe
late 50s 60s etc
but what's more shocking and disgusting
is i'm sorry i'm going to use word
disgusting because it is disgusting
he goes and shows it to his cousins and
little sister etc i'm just thinking to
myself like
what could be going through somebody's
mind to
not give a damn and just show this to
young girls
and boys what impression are you giving
to them
let's watch that as well let's watch and
look at the reaction of these young
innocent individuals and martial one of
them young
young girl she's wearing a hijab you
know and look at
where you're starting off from making
her watch an explicit
video you know like what kind of a role
model are you trying to be
like a young boy look at her look look
look look look that young girl is
twerking
that young girl is actually
twerking do you know how shocking
how shocking that is well
i've seen videos of when like when you
see
these young little girls non-muslims and
then you have non-muslims going into
outreach and be like
look why are you getting this young girl
to do this non-muslims
no muslims and you are a muslim you are
a muslim nobody's asking me to be
perfect
that these people do not care about you
they do not care about you
they don't care about you they care
about making a career for themselves
and if that means coming at the cost of
corrupting you
they're going to do that if a check is
put in front of them
and they are making large amounts of
money
and if that's going to come at the cost
of you
and the and his followers he's going to
do that
because you know why because shaytan is
not going to come
shaytan is not going to come here
shaytan is not going to come and say
do this she thought i was going to come
down and be like hey why don't you do a
music video
from the beginning because he knows
that's not going to be a good start for
you mate
your before your career starts within
the muslim community it's going to go
down
what does shaytan do slowly slowly
slowly
slowly step by step look how adam salah
has changed
what i want to do now is i just want to
show you guys
an interview so he hasn't he hasn't he's
having an interview on asian bbc radio
about this music thing yeah
look at the things that look at the
thing that he says can you see
why some people might assume that you do
have a responsibility to maybe
maintain a certain uh image of what a
young muslim is can you see why because
your
fan base is so young but doing this
music and this album is something that i
love doing it's something that
it's i see it as art and i'm telling a
story like
i'm telling a story to to my viewers of
what's going on in my life
so basically he's saying he's telling
the viewers what's going on in his life
so right now in his life
it looks like girls are licking his face
and he's living that lifestyle where
there's girls in his bed
i'm asking him to be perfect i'm not
saying adam's heart would be perfect no
no no
but at least have the shame to hide your
sins don't corrupt individuals what you
want to do with yourself
do it you know go you want to go through
your face you know like other youtubers
yeah
this brother has gone on a bit of a
ignorant phase
you have other youtubers who are going
on a pious face yeah on a piety face
yeah that's super
piety attack yeah brothers go through
your face
in private don't bring other people into
it you go through your face
but don't affect other people to be like
oh man let's just
throw the money in the air like i'm
doing it
as a way to explain myself and a way to
tell stories to
or for people to relate you see he's not
even making sense he doesn't unbelieve
over he doesn't look like he's he
doesn't know what he's talking about i'm
doing it while i throw money out
i'm just trying to tell a story what
story what are you talking about
also too so i can see why they think
you see that he didn't even answer that
responsibility but to hold
but the thing is i'm i'm mean i've
always been the way i am the same person
if you've been you and you've been
always you the same person as you
then why didn't you from day one do this
why didn't you get these girls and make
a music video on day one
why why did the real you come out later
why not then why didn't this happen two
years ago three years ago
why not so to be honest guys
uh that's about it uh i hope you guys
have benefited
um to be honest it's just a message out
there for you guys to understand
do not fall for public figures this goes
the same with me if you see me going
down this route
automatically unsubscribe unsubscribe
unsubscribe and subscribe
simple as i hope you guys can understand
who our lord is
yes and these are [ __ ] most merciful
and that we should not easily be able to
say under their judgment is going to be
me yeah i'm this shouldn't be coming out
of my mouth and
hopefully uh that's about it for me hope
you guys benefited please share this
with your friends and families
uh and let them watch some benefit from
as well assalamu alaikum and one of my
delay better careto